[Music]
we all know that valerent pistols are
completely busted but now L jumping the
corner goes ahead gets the head shot
extra take it down in the meantime 10
finding the kill one yet pushing forward
will also be able to finish him off
tries to go aggro gets right up
against how does he do it triple kills
in just about every pistol round whether
you're deleting someone with the
classics right click or one tapping them
with a sheriff valerent sidearms can do
some serious damage and yet there are
two specific Pistols that reign supreme
and the community has never been able to
agree on which one is King this going to
be huge he's going to spot all of them
right now 1 2 three
four looking for the ace right now and
it's about to be peaked out here so
Arrow to come out and he's going to win
this fight and he does with another head
shot that is tense he's got the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up in
Moose's face and he's getting a jumping
one as well on the thief I said this the
first time I call T this is his world
and we're just living in it there are
certain spray Downs that you typically
only see from the frenzy and some tap
fests that have become a staple with the
ghost every valorant player has a
preference but are your pistol buying
habits putting you at a disadvantage is
one of these pistols objectively better
than the other it's contained well by
Team Liquid K also gone for another
attempt
to no way in
[Applause]
hell okay so before we get to valeron's
Pistol meta I need you to check out our
new merch collection which includes our
onward and forward team let's get one
thing straight you are the best [__]
gamer on planet Earth and I think it's
time you started dressing the part shift
walking is for cowards smash that W key
and check out the score orts drop 2
available now all right so the frenzy
and the ghost have been compared
incessantly since basically the
beginning of valerant they obviously
have different use cases but because the
cost is almost the same people have been
led to wonder which one has better value
real ones probably remember that
throughout the first year of valerent
the frenzy only cost 400 credits
compared to the ghosts 500 meaning that
you could buy a frenzy and light armor
on pistol rounds and do some serious
damage some of you probably have fond
memories of that time others nightmares
why well in the early days of valerant
the frenzy was busted also unsuccessful
like how is he doing this with this F
[__] gun 33 70 HP going to get an
opportunity for one more flash point
brilliant but Nitro oh the cage it
covers himself up but none of these
players are touching it but Nitro comes
out of the cage oh coming out of the G
and he's doing just fine Nitro getting a
4K out of th air R eventually increased
the price of the frenzy to 500 credits
in February 2021 only to reduce the cost
to 450 when they nerfed the walking and
running accuracy of all pistols a few
months later this basically put the
frenzy and the ghost on equal footing in
terms of economy since there's no agent
for whom 50 credits is going to make or
break their buy so what was it that set
them apart well the frenzy is a machine
pistol capable of doing serious damage
from short range and often shines with a
bit of running gun the ghost on the
other hand is a silenced sidearm that
does well in mid to long range gunfights
and it's just generally more versatile
that being said there are a surprising
number of frenzy enjoyers out there I
will say the CZ is like a more broken
version of the frenzy and the MP9 is
basically like a stinger so it's like
you know coming from CS mean Leaf that's
what we we pride on right there uh the
gun I prefer is the frenzy because uh
the close range fights are like what I
uh typically try to do I don't like
doing the long range uh ghost one Taps
I'm not really like a an aim Labs uh
aimer I guess the frenzy has 13 round
mags with an automatic rate of fire
while the ghost has 15 round mags with a
slower semi-automatic rain of fire but
their damage fall off at distance is
what really sets the ghost apart it
deals 105 damage to the Head from 0 to
30 m meaning you can one tap enemies who
don't have armor compared to the
frenzy's 78 damage to the head which is
the same as the classic unlike the ghost
in the classic though the frenzy's
damage falloff starts after only 20 M
rather than 30 making it ideal at closer
ranges meanwhile the ghost has the
undocumented advantage of making an
extremely satisfying sound when you gush
enemies with
it head nice nice one enemy remain now
because the ghost is silenced it also
outperforms the frenzy when spamming
through smokes because its tracers
aren't visible to enemies you're much
less likely to get punished for spamming
through smokes because of this and
another area in which the ghost shines
is in terms of first shot accuracy it
has a first shot spread of point 3°
versus the frenzy's measly 65 everyone
who's ever used a frenzy has had a
moment where you got to cross hair on
someone's head and you shoot and it just
doesn't register and it just doesn't
feel good but despite this
understandable disadvantage some of the
best players in the world still swear by
the frenzy it's their weapon of choice
on pistol rounds and many of them even
choose to buy it when they're on an Eco
it's definitely better than the sheriff
and in some cases because of the money
the economy situation uh and it's easy
to get a a first K even if they're 150
Health it it still brings them down very
quick it's like a it's it's an automatic
pistol and despite it being the less
popular pistol players who opted for the
frenzy in the VCT earlier this year put
in work they know that he's in back site
foxy will be able to find the second
kill the pursuit now coming through but
sun is in foxy caught trying to remove
the dart what now Buzz taking down the
PCH coming in xar Spike down gets the
reload the kill 10 seconds remaining
gets the 4K
rrq wow it's the frzy meta right now
that was like a wall bang to see why of
100 are weak
though frenes are so good I wonder if
January 1st is the most popular
de drops first like on on account
registration by the way your friend you
do that cuz mine
doesn't not that I
use of course he is of he
is what similar to The Phantom and the
Vandal for most players it's just a
question of personal preference there
are those who only buy The Ghost and
those who swear by the frenzy still
there is a clear winner between the two
most people's preference is to buy the
ghost according to Valor buff over the
last 6 months the frenzy has only
accounted for6 % of all kills in ranked
the only gun that's worse than that is
the Shorty at 4% meanwhile the ghost is
actually the deadliest sidearm
accounting for 7% of all kills in ranked
over the same time period but as we know
Riot doesn't always balance their game
around us casuals so back in June they
decided to Nerf the frenzy Once More by
making it harder to control at long
range which some Pro believe finally
locked in the ghost as the gun to buy
thing it was loud last year they they
love the frenzy and I was I remember I
was telling like G2 at the time like we
all have to buy frenzies like it's too
op but that was before the Nerf I don't
know if people are going to be using it
as much because honestly it's just not
the same as it used to be like it used
to be so good and ever since they
changed the spread and The Recoil on it
it just does not feel good anymore I
even tried using it it's it feels too
random just doesn't feel like it's worth
it so I think this point it's pretty
fair to say that the ghost is
objectively better but there are
certainly still some frenzy stands out
there who swear by their sidearm of
choice but what we wanted to find out
was whether or not players actually find
more success with one gun over the other
at the pro level sure more people tend
to buy the ghost but that doesn't
necessarily just make it better are
people just buying it because they see
everyone else doing it or is the frenzy
genuinely worse we wanted to settle this
argument once in for all with some
statistics and for that I brought in
Colton because who loves valorant and
statistical based arguments more than he
does right buddy and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
all right valerin Champions ended a few
months ago and I may not exactly be a
dieh hard fan but n wanted to talk about
it so I'm here to share with you some
pretty interesting stats from the event
throughout Champions we saw some pretty
incredible pistol plays and thanks to
some help from valorin analyst willm
minder and stats from run it back we
know that the ghost was purchased a
total of 1,030 times throughout the
event while the frenzy was only
purchased
395 times and after everything we've
already mentioned that doesn't seem all
that surprising the ghost is just
generally the more popular option and
Pros really seem to understand why on
average players who purchased a ghost
managed to get a kill in 72.8% of rounds
while frenzy users only managed to get a
kill in 57 .4% so the ghost won pretty
handily if you look at the tournament as
a whole but if we narrow it down to just
pistol rounds things get a lot more
interesting players who purchased a
ghost on pistol rounds got theirs 83% of
the time but not even 3% behind them
were frenzy users who got a kill in
80.4% of pistol rounds in fact
88.5% of the total kills from either gun
came on pistol rounds so what does that
all mean well although the ghost is the
preferred weapon across the board the
frenzy is still a reliable option on
rounds 1 and 13 it saw less success on
eco rounds and half buys but considering
players purchased over twice as many
ghosts throughout the event that's not
too surprising but what I do find
interesting is that even given the much
larger sample size players using the
ghost still managed to maintain a really
high level of success even when they
were at an economic disadvantage now of
course Pros know how to use these guns a
hell of a lot better than your random
ranked teammates and they probably do a
much better job of putting themselves in
a position to get the most out of every
buy you may have a preference for one
gun or the other but the stats Don't Lie
the ghost is simply more effective in
more rounds and that was the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
although there are some di hards out
there who would have you believe that
the frenzy is God's gift to valerent the
ghost is actually better statistically
across the board from ranked to Pro Play
It's the Superior choice in practically
every situation and unless Riot suddenly
decides to shake up the pistol meta it
will likely remain that way for some
time but that doesn't mean that you
should never buy the frenzy valerant is
designed so that practically every
single gun is viable in certain
situations some of them even excel in
places they shouldn't so in terms of uh
weapon strengths and whatever I mean
even on pistol rounds you see all the
pistols half the time so it's like the
game's in a really good spot in my
opinion where there's there's a lot of
variety and ways you can play the game
and what you want to use inside the game
so if you prefer a certain weapon or
play style stick with it not every
player can frag out with a frenzy and
not every player can gush enemies with a
ghost ultimately the best weapons to use
in any game are the ones that help you
win so if that means defying convention
or ignoring stats completely so be it do
your
thing I I use the ghost on pistol rounds
on tside if I'm ever Eco I buy a frenzy
obviously the frenzy is insane it's so
good pistol round but pistol rounds I
like the
ghost yeah ghost is sick on pistol
especially on on on Attack on CT a
frenzy because you can play the close
angles obviously is is really good but
if I'm tside a pistol round ghost man
it's goed